Congressman Stuart Kaplan former FBI now
practicing Attorney question was the
legal process to get your phone was a
search warrant
yes it was all right now Congressman
because I've been in that situation I
will assume the technology that's out
there that the bureau uses is called
sellbrite and that's a software that
will mirror your phone I assume the
conversation went something like this
listen congresswoman let's make your
life a lot easier give us your password
because if you don't give us the
password we're going to keep your phone
in finita it may take us up to a year or
two to crack that code so I assume you
realize that I would need my phone back
so you cooperate and gave your password
is that correct
essentially yeah I scripted almost
exactly
and and so you realize though sir and I
would have counseled you though and
that's only because I've been there I
would have said listen agents good to
meet you go pound sand here's my phone
but I'm not giving you my password and
good luck cracking that code by the way
on cracking an Apple iPhone probably a
year maybe even longer and by that time
you know who knows what happens but
listen in any event I just just wanted
to make sure I understand the legal
process now I have a question for you
because this will maybe cast some
information that may assist the viewing
audience
you were left a copy of the warrant what
district or what jurisdiction was that
warrant issued out of
uh
uh well I can't remember I don't know if
it was in New Jersey or Washington DC
actually I think it was in Pennsylvania
they went they went to where they were
in Pennsylvania got that warrant okay
but I think that I think so I'm not a
lawyer so look and I don't travel with a
lawyer I appreciate your counsel now I
wish
they'll have a uh ausa's number on it
that if your lawyer has any questions
you can contact this ausa I assume it
was a 202 number or someone in DC
someone had to Justice uh yeah yeah I
think so and I guess I guess I could
have said you know before I hold before
I hand you the phone let me contact my
attorney no I understand that no and
congressman and listen again because
we're having open attorney-clined
Communications at this point now I'm
joking but do I understand and this is
what would begrudge me and again this
goes to my point where I think the
bureau has really taken a bad turn here
Congressman do and by the way you don't
have to answer this I'm making light of
it because I probably already know the
answer do I understand that prior to the
agent showing up at your beautiful
vacation retreat your lawyers or you had
zero contact with anybody through doj
telling you or asking their curiosity to
just sit down and talk to you about what
may be in your phone this was is just
all no contact whatsoever yeah so you
know the day they showed up was the day
I learned about it right no and and
there lies the rub with me and I will
tell you that you know in addressing and
investigating political figures such as
yourself it goes to the highest level up
to the director of the FBI and and when
I say up to the director there's got to
be 20 Indian chiefs in between the
director and who has to sign off on that
and that's where begrudgingly I have a
problem because so many eyes had to have
seen this and the Optics and the
perception is so bad and just is so
distasteful that someone like yourself
who now has said and I think I've heard
you say this I'm an open book whatever I
would say on camera or off camera it's
going to be the same so I assume
Congress if anybody had any interest in
talking to you you would have sat down
and told them what you would answer
their questions
if the Department of Justice or FBI
would have called my attorneys and said
look we want to sit with the congressman
we want to look at his phone or whatever
it's not the j6 so-called committee
which is a which is a sham right that's
a one-sided of course A Star Chamber
that already has determined the outcome
before they ever talk to anybody right
but this is different no the level is
never made right and and if I can add
this because because this is something
that you will find I think particularly
interesting and egregious the Inspector
General we found out the Inspector
General was involved in the decision to
come seize my phone the FBI and doj
Inspector General and and how do you
like that well I'll tell you what the
reason is the reason is because after
the fiascos that have been going on and
on and on there is now An Inspector
General investigation with respect to
the ethics and the Integrity of what's
going on in in at the FBI headquarters
yeah this is this is the day after they
rated the president's house the
Inspector General was involved in the
seizure of a sitting member of
congress's phone and I don't say it that
way because I'm better than anybody else
I'm just citizen Perry right but but at
the same time they know that there's
there's attorney-client privilege on
this phone because they know it's my
personal phone and they know I have an
attorney so says the FBI agent that I
spoke to on the street but also I'm a
sitting member of Congress and in the
Constitution there's this thing called
speech and debate which protects the
legislature from the king from the
executive branch because the king or the
president isn't supposed to be able to
intimidate or coerce legislators to do
what he wants to bend to his will to
bend the knee and to not say thing on
behalf of their constituent his
constituents
um and of course they're trying to
pierce that Veil right now and I'm alone
out here in the world trying to hold
back the the kingdom of President Biden
against a couple hundred years of of of
you know of Courts and and decisions and
litigation that that that that separates
the legislative branch from the
executive branch so that we don't have a
kingdom yeah well you know the travesty
and the concern and listen I'm sure you
have very learned and experienced
counsel but my immediate concern and
which is
serious is this cell bright technology
does not differentiate between
attorney-client privilege Communications
and that that may just be not and the
problem with that is you realize that a
case agent or the evidence response team
is going to go through each and every
Communication in that phone whether it's
privileged or not and their lies the rub
where you would have and should have had
the opportunity to have your lawyers say
look I'll tell you what we're going to
segregate the congressman's phone we
will download the phone mutually at a
mutually agreeable time and location but
we are going to before we turn over
we're going to segregate that
information that we know is attorney
client privileged and should not fall
into the hands of the Department of
Justice and there is where there's an
agreement put in place to protect
someone like himself and to protect all
of us so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign